Welcome back.
Now let me apologize.
That last problem, I think I
rushed it a little bit because
I have to get under this
10-minute YouTube limit.
But let me know.
Send me a message on that last
video if you don't think the
explanation was as satisfying as
you would like it to be or
if you're still confused.
With that said, let
me move on.
Problem number 9 on page 461.
The decimal number above, and
they wrote 5.101001000100001,
and it keeps going.
The decimal number above
consists of only 1's and 0's
to the right of the
decimal point.
The first 1 is followed
by one 0.
The second 1 is followed
by two 0's.
Right?
The second 1 is followed by
two 0's, the third 1 is
followed by three 0's,
and so forth.
What is the total number of 0's
between the 98th and 101st
1 in this decimal number?
Well, the first 1 is followed
by one 0, the second 1 is
followed by two 0's.
The third 1 is followed
by three 0's.
Right?
So the 50th 1 is going to
be followed by 50 0's.
Right?
The nth 1 is followed
by n 0's.
So the 98th is going to
be followed by 98 0's.
Right?
So you're going to have a 1,
then you're going to have 98
0's, then you're going
to have the 99th 1.
That's going to be followed
by 99 0's.
That's just the pattern
that they set up.
Then you're going to
have the 100th 1.
That's going to be followed
by 100 0's.
Then you're going to have
the 101st 1, right?
And we don't care about the 0's
that are after the 101st
1, because they said how many
0's are between the 98th 1 and
the 101st 1.
So I mean, another way to draw
it, as you know, we had a
bunch of 0's on this, and
then this is the 98th 1.
Then we're going to have
a bunch of 0's.
We're going to have
98 0's here.
Then you're going to have a 1.
Then you're going to have
a bunch of 0's.
This time you're going
to have 99 0's.
This is going to
be the 99th 1.
Then you have the 100th 1, which
is followed by 100 0's.
Then you have the 101st 1.
And we don't care about
this 0's after it.
So this is how many 0's
are in between.
We just have to add up this.
See, 8 plus 9 is 17.
So it's 98 plus 99 is 207.
So it's 307 0's.
Is that one of the choices?
Sorry.
I'm doing my math wrong.
See, this is how I know it's
late at night and I
should be in bed.
But 98 plus 99 is 197
plus 100 is 297.
So that's how many 0's are
between the 98th and 101st 1
in this decimal number.
Problem 10.
Let me switch colors.
This color is making
me sleepy.
f of x is equal to 3 minus
2x squared over x for all
non-zero x, then f of 2.
Well, we just take a 2.
f or 2, we're just taking a
2 and sticking it here.
So everywhere we see an x,
we replace it with a 2.
So it becomes 3 minus 2-- we
put a 2 in there, let me
switch colors for emphasis-- 2
squared over-- that's not the
same purple-- over 2.
Just so you know where
that 2 came from,
that's f of 2, right?
Everywhere where there
was an x, I just
replaced it with a 2.
Now I just evaluate this.
So 3 minus 2 times 2
squared-- so that 2
squared is 4-- over 2.
So 3 minus 8 over 2 equals--
well 3 minus 8 is minus 5-- so
it's minus 5 over 2.
That is choice d.
OK, it looks like we
have a geometry
problem for number 11.
Let me draw this.
There's two lines like
this and like this.
These lines are perpendicular,
x degrees, y degrees.
This line is l.
This line m.
In the figure above, l is
perpendicular to n.
Right? l is perpendicular to n,
this is a 90 degree angle,
and x is greater than
90 degrees.
So this angle is larger
than 90 degrees.
So they didn't draw
it that way.
So this is actually probably
angling down a bit.
Which of the following
must be true?
y is less than 90 degrees?
So let's see.
So, it's interesting, because
who cares what's happening up
here, right?
If you have a line-- let me
just draw it like this.
Let me draw it with the
lines actually.
Let me draw it like if you have
one line like this, and
then this line like this.
If this right here is x,
x is greater than 90
degrees, and this is y.
We know that these two angles
are going to be supplementary
to each other, that they
add up to 180, right?
X plus y is equal
to 180 degrees.
So if x is greater than 90, then
we know that y has to be
less than 90, right?
So that's what we
know is true.
We could look at the
other choices.
y is definitely not going
to be greater than 90.
to be equal to 90.
If y is equal to 90 and x is
greater than 90, then these
two angles are going to be
greater than 180 degrees,
which we know it can't be.
n is perpendicular to m.
We know that's not true because
if this is 90 degrees,
then this is also 90 degrees.
But this angle is a
corresponding angle, but it's
not the same.
So they're not parallel lines.
This line is actually, I should
drawn it like this.
Actually I drew a straight line
when I didn't want to.
It's going to be skewed
down like this, right?
Because x degrees
is more than 90.
Then l is parallel to m, and
we also know that's not the
case for the same reason.
So it's choice a.
All right.
Let's see if I can fit in this
last problem within the
10-minute window.
Problem number 12.
In the the xy plane, the line
with the equation y is equal
to 5x minus 10 crosses the
x-axis at the point with the
coordinates a, b.
So this is where it crosses
the x-axis.
So that's where it crosses
What is the value of a?
OK, so when something crosses
the x-axis, what's
the value of b?
What's the y-value?
Well, the y-value, we know,
is going to be 0, right?
I mean, I could draw that.
If I draw coordinates, and
if this is a line,
let me draw the line.
We'll say the line looks
something like this.
Where something crosses the
x-axis, that's going to be
right here, when y equals 0.
So all we have to do is
say that y equals 0
and solve for x.
So y equals 0 is equal
to 5x minus 10.
5x is equal to 10,
x is equal to 2.
So this is the point
right here.
This is the point 2 comma 0.
So a is going to be equal to
choice d, which is 2, which is
the answer.
I think that's all the time
I have for in this video,
because the next one
looks like I'll
have to draw a table.
So I will see you soon.